طبعا هذه الاصوات لا تقارن ابدا بالاصوات
السابقه التي شهدناها خلال الايام الماضيه
وخلال ساعات الصباح الاولى اليوم كان
الاشتباكات اكثر حده ولكن يبدو بان هناك
اطلاق نار متقطع في محيط مبناه القياده
العامه تحديدا كما نشاهد في هذه اللقطات
المباشره من شاشه العربيه
لمتابعه التطورات الصحيه معنا من الخرطوم
الدكتور عطيه عبد الله عطيه سكرتير نقابه
الاطباء في السودان دكتور عطيه كيف هو
الوضع الطبي الان في العاصمه الخرطوم هل
هناك من ارقام جديده بشان القتلى
والمصابين من الطرفين ومن المدنيين ايضا
في هذا الاشتباكات
اولا كل عام وانتم بخير
وخالص التعازي لكل الجماهير الشعب
السوداني وامنيات الصحه والعافيه لكل
المصابين والجرحى وعوده الحميده لكل
المفقودين نعم الوضع يزداد سواء كل لحظه
بلحظه نحن حسب التقرير التي اصدرناه صبيحه
هذا اليوم الاعداد تصل الى 200 وخمسين
شهيدا اكثر من الف واربعين مصابا هذا وسط
المدنيين فقط
وايضا هو في المستشفيات التي وصلنا اليها
خروج متوالي لعدد من المستشفيات خارج
الخدمه وايضا هنالك عدد من المسلسلات
الاخرى ايضا هي على حافه الاغلاق كل هذه
العوامل ستضر جدا بالنظام الصحي في
السودان الذي هو ايضا يترنح على حافيه
حافه
السقوط ايضا هنالك يعني كما ذكر زميلكم
قبل قليل هو تبادل اطلاق النار في كل مكان
هو يحد من امكانيه الوصول الكوادر الطبيه
الى المستشفيات وايضا تغيير تلك الكوادر
التي كانت تعمل منذ قبيحه السبت كل
المعينات الطبيه نفذت تماما كل مخزون
الوقود من الجازولين هو نفسه تماما في عدد
من المستشفيات انقطاع التيار الكهربائيه
انقطاع الماء في عدد من المستشفيات يعقد
يعقد المشهد وايضا يسبب
حرجا يعني التام للكوادر الطبيه لعدم
امكانياتهم تقديم اي شيء
للمرضى وبالذات المرضى المنومين اولئك
الذين يحتاجون الى
غسيل كلى او الذين متواجدون في غرف
العنايه المكثفه
بشكل واضح بان هناك الكثير من المستشفيات
التي خرجت من الخدمه اقصد بانها غير قادره
على استقبال المزيد من المرضى او التعامل
مع المرضى الموجود داخل المستشفيات بسبب
نقص الوقود الكوادر التي كانت محاصره
لايام طويله عدم قدره الكوادر الطبيه خارج
تلك المستشفيات على الالتحاق بالعمل داخل
تلك المستشفيات ولكن هل صحيح بان عدد من
المستشفيات قد تعرض للقصد بشكل مباشر او
حتى غير مباشر خلال الايام الماضيه
نعم 14 مستشفى تعرض للقصف المباشر او
الغير مباشر في النهايه هي تعرضت لدمار
جزئي او دمار كامل ايضا تعرض احد عشر
طبيبا للقتل
في هذه الاحداث صبيحه السبت وهنا نرسل
تعازي الحاره لاسرهم ايضا هنالك عدد من
الكوادر الطبيه تعرضت للعنف وبعض منهم
مصاب
للعنف الذي واجهوه في الشوارع اثناء
قيامهم باداء واجبهم تجاه المستشفيات
القادمه
والمرضاهم هذا الرقم لا يمكن ان يمر مرور
الكرام هل تتحدث عن مقتل 11 طبيبا سودانيا
خلال الاحداث الاخيره لدى الدائم للاهم في
الخرطوم
قادر الطبيه وثلاثه من طلاب كليات الطيب
تعدت اسباب قتلهم اما بالرصاص المباشر او
سقوط دهانات داخل منازلهم نعم احد عشر في
مجموعهم كبير ولكن كيف يمكن للمستشفيات
التي خرجت من الخدمه في الخرطوم العوده
مجددا خاصه في ظل هذه الظروف التي تحتاج
الى وجود كوادر طبيه ومستشفيات تعمل
لاستقبال هذا الكم الهائل من المصابين
الامر بسيط اذا اذا صدقت النوايا الامر
بسيط يعني فتح ممرات امنه للوصول لهذه
الكوادر يحل مشكله الكادر الطبي تماما
ايضا وصول الاسعاف وايضا وصول العربات
الناقله للمعدات الطبيه هو من الامر من
السهوله بمكان اذا توافق طرفي الازمه في
السودان لوقف هذه الحرب العباسيه فورا
يمكن تدارك ما يمكن تداركه حتى اللحظه اذا
صدقت النوايا
الذي نتحدث عنه هنالك عدد من المنظمات
يعني تستطيع ان هي ان تحرك كوادرها وايضا
تستطيع
تحرك مخازنها اتجاه هذه المنتجات اذا تم
فتح ممرات امنه الامر هو بسيط اذا اذا
صدقت النوايا كما تم اجراء الضباط
المصريين او العساكر المصريين يمكن كذلك
فتح ممرات امنه لمرور الاطباء والكوادر
الطبيه وفتح هذه المستشفيات قبل ذلك نحن
رسالتنا لطرفي النزاع بالخروج الفوري من
هذه المنتجات وعدم اتخاذها
منطلقه لعملياتهم العسكريه
وهذا ايضا تصريح مهم هل هناك بعض
المستشفيات التي يستخدمها احد الطرفين
كملجا او مكان يشن معاركه الاخيره
كل الطرفين يحتل بعضا من المستشفيات ايضا
نحن رسالتنا لطرفي الصراع بعدم استهداف
ايضا ايا كانت لمن تتبع لهذا او ذاك في
النهايه هي يعني مركز طبي او وحده صحيه او
قل هي منشاه طبيه لا يجوز مهاجمتها اي
منشاه طبيه هي تقدم خدمات طبيه لا يجوز
مهاجمتها تم مهاجمه مستشفى الشرطه ايضا
الكوادر الطبيه في مستشفى الضمان تعرضوا
للعنف
وتعرضوا لتعريض قسمهم الطبي للخطر بطلب
احد طرفي النزاع بعدم علاج الطرف الاخر
هذا مهدد خطير يعني كل هذه التجاوزات التي
حصلت دكتور عطيه هل قمتم برصدها وهل انتم
مستعدون لتقديمها
للمنظمات سواء الحكوميه او الدوليه في
سبيل ملاحقه الاشخاص المتورطين في انتهاك
حرمه المستشفيات السودانيه
نعم كله مرصود بالدقيقه واللحظه ايا كان
تبعيه هذه المؤسسه لمن تتبع هي في النهايه
مؤسسه طبيه التعدي عليه هو جريمه نحن
لدينا رفض كامل لكل العمليات اللا انسانيه
لكل الجرائم العسكريه التي تمت في القطاع
الطبي مستعدون لتقديمها متى ما سنحت او
متى ما توقفت هذه الحرب لذلك نحن رسالتنا
لهم ان التاريخ يسجل دعك من القانون
الدولي حتى القانون المحلي حتى المواطنون
هنا يعرفون من هاجم مستشفياتهم لكل
الاشخاص الذين لا يستطيعون تلقي العلاج
داخل منازلهم وكانت اصابتهم تستدعي توجههم
الى المستشفيات هل هناك مستشفيات بعينها
حسب التوزيع الجغرافي للعاصمه الخرطوم
يمكن على الاقل الذهاب اليها رغم ضعف
الامكانات
نعم نحن نحاول جاهدين في فتح منتجات طرفيه
حتى يتمكن المواطنون من تلقي العلاج لدينا
الان عدد تشغيل عدد من المستشفيات الطرفيه
التي بامكانها يعني ان تؤدي واجبها حتى
انجلها هذه الازمه نعم كما ذكرته الوصول
الى اغلب المستشفيات الان فيه صعوبه كبيره
ايضا حلول مؤقتا نحن نحاول مع زملائنا في
باقي الولايات في تحويل عدد من الحالات
التي تستدعي
عمليات جراحيه عاجله لا يمكن يعني اجراها
في الخرطوم للظروف الامنيه او لنقص
المعينات الطبيه نعم دكتور عطيه عبد الله
عطيه سكرتير نقابه الاطباء في السودان
شكرا جزيلا لك ايضا مناشده من الاطباء في
السودان للتدخل من اجل تمويل تلك
المستشفيات التي خرجت على الخدمه بسبب
شحال امكانيات وايضا تعرضها للاعتداء من
قبل طرفي النزاع في السودان نتابع لمتابعه
المزيد الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات